sometimes it just can't wait till you
get home but with the questionable
sanitary state of public bathrooms one
has to wonder should you hover above or
cover the seat with toilet paper are you
really at risk of contamination it may
be surprising but in a typical home your
cutting board has around 200 times more
fecal matter on it than the average
toilet seat even worse is the dish
sponge which has around 200 thousand
times more bacteria and while we've all
seen our fair share of dirty public
toilets the truth is if it passes the
site test and seems okay it's probably
cleaner than most other objects in a
bathroom regardless your skin is
designed as an excellent barrier to
microorganisms even though some bacteria
such as a coli can survive on a toilet
seat
indefinitely if you don't have an open
sore near it or there isn't something
foreign or sharp on the seat the
bacteria isn't likely to get inside your
body and while placing a layer of clean
paper on the seat may reduce your
contact with germs it's worth
considering a few things first the
species of bacteria typically found on
toilet seats are common skin microbes
that most people already carry meaning
they pose little threat unless you're
immunocompromised and secondly chances
are microorganisms are already over
everything in the bathroom seriously
simply flushing a toilet creates
aerosolized bacteria meaning that that
toilet paper itself is likely
contaminated the risk of infection comes
most frequently from improper
hand-washing followed by touching your
mouth eyes or other bodily openings if
you're that worried about germs and
insist on wasting toilet paper for your
tush you should probably be in a
biohazard suit because either way you're
being exposed on the other hand hovering
over the toilet is a perfect alternative
if you're grossed out and gets a little
workout in there as well otherwise sit
with confidence wash your hands and when
you're done waltz over to that door and
touch the handle that everybody else who
didn't wash their hands touch - thanks
to audible.com for giving you a free
audio book of your choice at audible.com
slash ASAP audible is the leading
provider of audiobooks with over 150,000
downloadable titles across all types of
literature checkout think like a freak
which is by the same guys who made
Freakonomics you can download this
audiobook or another of your choice for
free at audible.com/asap then use their
free app to listen on your Apple Windows
or Android
device special thanks to audible for
making these videos possible and
subscribe for more weekly science videos